hello it is October 14 2022 at least
where I slash we are
and it's active guest stream number 29.1
we are Revisited by Shawna Dobson and
today we'll be discussing the paper
with Dobson and Fields making up our
minds imaginative deconstruction in math
art 1920 to the present we'll have a
presentation with some interspersed
discussion followed by more discussion
so thank you again for joining and
please take it away
hi Daniel thank you again for the invite
thank you for noticing our paper and for
welcoming us here
so we will be discussing and
deconstructing
um the idea of
personality and mind and self through a
very beautiful interlay of math art as
we call it so um we're going to lay down
the sort of heavy argument about what
we're actually lacing together and then
we're going to end with juxtaposing two
mathematical Giants growth and Deacon
erdogs and using them as a case point to
evaluate
this investigation of ours into why
we're saying the Mind Is Made Up and
what the self is
so it's a little text heavy but we're
going to pause every once in a while so
that we can get um you know understand
what's actually happening here I think
no figure would do justice to what we're
saying possibly the perfectoid shape I
have on the front which I've talked
about before but I'll save the Mappy
part for the ending part
so the main idea what we say
um oh and I want to say we also gave a
snippet of this talk at the recent
models of Consciousness conference in
Stanford so people want to look at it
there but you can find out the the paper
on the fill archive right now so the
main idea is that the cognitive Sciences
actually tell us that the self is a
construct so we're actually going to use
mathematics to give it full impression
expression and actually abstract the
self to what we're calling a grothendiq
site so the self
is going to be what we what Deluge and
guitar you have called a hasadi so it's
an actual ephemeral thisness and nowness
and so we actually claim that we
actually make up our minds so when we're
saying making up our minds we actually
are we're playing there
so that our acts are public and that
they communicate effectively becomes
what we're going to call a daily
theistic Paradox so it's a limit Paradox
that happens when font runs up against
its own limits and as you all know like
Chris and I are not afraid to sort of
like let's take this concept and push it
uh push it till it breaks or in the
words of like bards push it past the
antipractical recrimination so we love
playing around in this heavy heavy
intersection of math philosophy
philosophy of mind
um to figure out like
what is this self so we invoke a new
mathematical formalism by Peter schultza
and Dustin Claussen called a condensed
set to formalize the notion of a self as
a site so we're going to mathematize
what the self is and um then we're going
to create an event-dependent constructed
time of retrospective and prospective
memories event dependent not that it's
independent and so this is an
alternative to the objective time of
temporal logic and its descendants so we
discussed this in the paper and I'm
trying to get a snippet so in essence
this new condensed formalism that's
going to invoke some sheaves gives a
representation to how a self as a site
experiences memory so if you remember
Chris and I are very puzzled by why why
do you experience memories not not why
do you have them you can have some kind
of like you know acceptation argument
about why you actually have a memory
right and going down the DNA line and
stuff like that but why do you
experience memory and can you imagine
the first creature that actually did
so if we actually authenticate an object
by observing it again and that requires
a lot of memory for the ram
um and we conclude that an inferential
action or a creation has returned so we
play around with this notion of return
in the sense of eternal return instance
of Nietzsche Duluth does a very
brilliant discussion of what eternal
return actually means that nothing is
actually returning the only thing that
returns is pure Multiplicity
so it is a world without being without
unity and so we love that world
so if authentication claims that
something Returns what does return
because quantum mechanics is not going
to say that so in the pink I've
highlighted that can this notion of
science or this condensed frame this
condensed structure can then actually
reframe authentication
dialecticistically this is what I'm very
very perplexed in so
if you have a notion of dilethias in
which we do anytime you have a
self-reference a system referencing
itself is going to create these
paradoxes
what does that mean for us in terms of
authentication so we're going to
conclude that the greatest imaginary
construct is really our own mind but to
call these constructs ours is to abuse
notation so
um we call the I reified we say that I
have an experience that we actually
reify so it's something that you've
actually made up Chris said this
brilliantly and I put it together and
identity is a short-term weak
approximation something you quote
get away with but not for very long so
again Chris and I are saying that time
is not this continuous like beautiful
thing that it's actually pieced pieced
pieced and above every point in time
lies a Sheaf and I know I've discussed
sheafs before so above every point in uh
every Point Yeah It's Tricky so if every
point is modeled it's something singular
and you authenticate at every point then
what you're actually doing is like a
grand interpolation so to say that you
have an identity is actually tricky so
quantum mechanics is actually going to
justify this proof it's going to say
well isolated systems undergo unitary
Evolution which produces non-separable
States so this is irrefutable so we say
me plus everything butt means it is an
isolated system and we take everything
seriously so asymptotically I am
actually entangled with everything else
so neitheros has a separate identity
right so we are we're open we're opening
our arms and saying you know someone
help so maybe we only get away with what
this is in each instantaneous experience
this is what we're saying uh it includes
experiences of memories but it's
completely meaningless other than for
instant to me instantaneously
so that meaning is something that we
actually have to continually assign to
this notion of instantaneousness so in
this paper we focus on a few questions
that we say what are we actually doing
when we do mathematics or art or science
or philosophy that explains the actual
correlation what we've called math art
so what are we actually doing when we do
anything a creative act in general so
how do we account for that trajectory
through the 20th century it's very very
heavy that you move from a sense of
solidity into extreme abstraction
fragmentation depersonalization why have
all the creative disciplines followed
this trajectory they seem to abstract
subtract uh what are we left with so you
know we claim that well what it's been
deconstructed across all the creative
disciplines is actually the self the
self in particular The Confident
Cartesian self as an independent
objective Observer and a directed
voluntary actor so this is done so in
while we were working I asked Chris all
the time why can we never actually
access what causes a thought and so he
would say well no finite system can
contain a complete representation of its
own Dynamics okay you run into a problem
with self-reference why are there no
things in themselves well because
quantum theory is going to strike us as
self-evidently true at least as a
description of the interaction between
any finite system and its world and its
world
I still to this day ask what is a
thought
what is a thought and why is it that
maybe my thought is somebody else's
memory
what is that if somebody's memory my
thought you know delus talks about this
body without organs which I'm going to
get to and he opens the the paragraph
with at any rate you have one
so thoughts what are these at any rate
you have them uh so we're just we're
we're grasping here a thought is a modal
as in like a sensory mode it's an
immodal experience that's generated by
imagination and not perception
but what does imagination mean from an
actual like quantum theory perspective
so it must be a source of classical
information
so hence it must be written on a
boundary but it differs in a significant
way from an action on quote the world
because it's my imaginary world so we're
really we really dive into this paper is
like how do imagination and sensation
compete so there's a central
contradiction which I'm going to just
kind of go quickly through experiencers
really want to understand the source of
their experience
but it's actually impossible in
principle all you really do is just
overlay the experience with the theory
and then but what produce them is still
inaccessible in principle so category
Theory can help mitigate this a little
bit so you know there's always going to
be morphisms acting on whatever
structure we call it imminent so
morphisms you deem something as imminent
you have morphisms acting on this
structure
um otherwise you would have zero change
otherwise you would have fixed agents we
call it of temporal with zero that would
experience becoming but they never
become
so there is there would be no change
um yeah so the fundamental contradiction
any philosophy of becoming is that it
requires an assumption of processes
outside of any possible experience so
we're going to use sheaves and category
Theory to kind of get through this so
one of our main ideas is linking
imagination and the free energy
principles so we're actually going to
say that all imaginative activity is
both constructive and active we actually
have an agent a literal sense of action
by the agent all the agents actually on
on their world so using the variational
free energy principle we're going to say
we consider all creative activity
including all imaginative activity is
actually problem solving we're creation
we're creating novelty and uncertainty
in the service of testing and improving
a model of the experience World 100
percent
so acting creativity is you're actually
going to act on the world with the
intention of provoking an informative
response from the world so we say to
make artists to perform an experiment an
immediate consequence of this is that
all art is provocative experimental all
art is informative just as science is
informative to the extent and in
proportion and it's provocative and
experimental so we really hit this hard
we go right and right into it and we say
you know mathematics is actually going
to exemplify and express the very
particular dissolution of the self with
the greatest Clarity and poetry for some
reason mathematics can get a horrible
represent reputation that it's like
actually like devoid of creativity we're
saying it's not so Gotham makes notion
of a site it actually really
encapsulates what this whole notion it
removes the solidity and locatedness of
the traditional idea of a point
right classical physics is based on the
idea of modeling particles as points
math is that the growth index side is
actually going to kind of destroy that
it replaces the notion of a point with
something that is structureless and
ephemeral and moreover the notion of a
condensed set is going to be like a
notion of sheaves on a point so it's no
longer about the point so we've kind of
like thrown out ontology with that so
category theory is going to allow these
structures to be transferred and then um
so we're going to introduce the society
line and we're going to look at Francis
Bacon's work as like an artistic
provocateur of this stuff so when we say
our greatest construct is like you know
our mind we're left with we're left with
the question of how we as artists or
scientists or as Bayesian uncertainty
minimizers how can we actually see each
other as fellow agents communicate and
share ideas this is actually really
beautiful makes you ask what is language
and what does it actually mean to say
that art and math are actually languages
what does it mean to be a speaker or a
writer when the deconstructionist
challenge is you know challenge is the
very notion of objectivity and say from
bars that text Unity lies not in its
origin but in its destination that's
powerful not in its origin but it's
dependent on the person reading it so
quoting bars again we will no longer be
fooled by The Arrogant anti-practical
recriminations of good Society in favor
of the very thing it sets aside ignores
Smothers or destroys so we're going
apart and through the actual notion of
what is mined what is self
so does a shared semantics can it even
be be assumed so when we say that all
action is created we're going to get a
little neurological here
um creativity it actually poses a
complete Paradox to the very antiseptic
Western philosophical tradition which is
saying that you know it values
reflective deliberate rules-based
thinking type 2 cognition although it's
a little more wild which is the
immediate intuitive unreflective type 1
or process one judgment
so Chris is heavily trained in this
section rate of insight it actually has
the phenomenology of type 1 cognition
but a greater value than most type 2
cognition it's called the outlier right
so we're actually putting together a
phenomenology of the outlier
so you know and again the Western
discomfort is understandable uh one of
the key attributes of an outlier is it's
unpredictable unpredictability so the
academy from like Plato onward you know
is designed to render the insights of
others formulaic and reproducible
so but then you've got you what's
beautiful are these flow states of
cognition uh super athletes go into this
state right um in which activities are
performed with the automaticity that
comes with deep experience and expertise
so you have something automatic that's
actually coming from you know excellent
trained but you always talk about anyone
in Flow State they say I'm getting out
of my way there is no eye anymore so you
combine the phenomenology of type 1
cognition with the feeling of ease or
Bliss or ecstasy or automatic pilot
whatever they call it you know and you
get a best performance out of it so I'll
talk a few more slides and then we'll
pause for like any any like putting
together right before we get to Francis
Bacon so we say imagination and
sensation compete this is actually
really beautiful to me
um uh Chris and I find ourselves on
opposite sides of the of the a Fantasia
Spectrum which is like the a Fantasia
um is uh classified as uh someone that
it does not have a or it is a deficit in
a very Rich visualization versus the
hyper Fantasia which is someone who has
so much richer visualization and memory
that the reality seems um dull compared
to the actual imaginative experience
right that the imagination is so
overwhelming so it's beautiful that we
write on opposite sides of this spectrum
and we can and I think that's what makes
this work so powerful so if imagination
sensation compete how well deliberate
thought what is deliberate thought so
it's a sequence of ideas that's
presented to Consciousness but by
unconscious processes
so I found this curious so the real work
is happening below the threshold of
awareness we've always asked what are
these fundamental units of life if
anyone knows anyone who's really sick
the personality is definitely the last
thing that sort of comes online it is
are the organs functioning is the heart
functioning and then comes little
personality and appetite in these things
so what is this threshold of awareness
what are these fundamental units of Life
why should so much be going on below it
why so then we have this hint
imagination maybe we can gleam a little
bit of what's going on neurologically
about what's happening in the
imaginative realm so we say the ability
to have sensory and emotional
experiences without engaging sensory
input
so this is uh Chris and Rosalyn and
Andrew and Hannah have tried to identify
what imagination is it's sensory though
it is sensory because it does engage
this same large-scale functional neural
networks that process sensory inputs I
myself did not know this I myself and I
told Chris I said you know when I'm
doing a lot of math or something I try
not to leave I find myself uh not able
to operate like heavy machinery and I've
spoken out about this like very very
honestly and he was like Shanna that's
because those they actually compete for
the same hardware and I said you've got
to be kidding me so he in the paper he
really he gives an example of like one
of his professors that would speak but
was holding the wall at the same time to
remember that the wall is there but the
imaginary field is so full so we talk
about resource sharing so sensation
imagination compete they render inner
speech difficult in noisy environments
and visualization difficult during
visually demanding tasks like driving
you don't want to be like thinking of
thinking of something like a perfectoid
spit in your driving like that is a red
light you know stop so sensory
deprivation actually enhances
imagination why so we I'll just go
quickly through reality monitoring
there's um you know the unintentional
blindness of abstract thinker somebody
like me you cannot physically see the
outside because your mind is thinking of
everything else this can be chalked up
to competition from imagination so again
sensory networks can be taken over by
imagination and then imaginative
experiences episodic memories and
thinking these are very present to
awareness because being both sensory and
emotional they're create they're treated
by the brain as both important so this
gets really interesting so this this
reality monitoring Network involving the
most phylogenetically recent areas of
the prefrontal cortex really has the
task of distinguishing sensory inputs
from imagination
do we have a distinction can I tell
what's real versus what the meta change
and we want to label them as such an
awareness so
um in Neuroscience you know you can we
we experience these imaginings as
memories and pictures and you know we're
going to use them to understand the
world so the picture of the brain is
employing all of its available resources
to model the world right um and to act
appropriately within it has been given a
beautiful elegant mathematical
formulation for standard fields that
both done this the free energy principle
we've worked on this that any sense any
system will behave so as to minimize to
the extent possible it's uncertainty
about its environment's future actions
on it absolutely 100 here so we
formalize it as a variational free
energy principle so it's actually a
thermodynamic principle that applies to
all classical and Quantum physical
systems not just to brains so we're
actually it drives the process of active
inference incorporates learning about
the world as it presents itself actively
probing the world to provoke informative
responses so that you're constantly
performing all of this you know um is
beautiful and it also leads to an it's
it's Dynamic it is dynamic and we're
actually trying to figure out what is
the self and a free energy principle and
the uh what happens to the self as you
know as you apply variation to this and
um the time to support such an elegant
Theory like fep so I should pause there
to see anything else before we launch
and just to the next chunk of the actual
Arty stuff
great well there's already so much I
know I'm sorry what are some of the
formalisms I'll look forward to it a few
comments on the point of math and heavy
machinery they say don't derive and
drive that's what I've heard that's
great um then on the type 1 and type 2
and it made me think about how rather
than a category
of thought
or simple modes that are exclusionary to
each other type 1 and type 2 are like
axes in a space of behaviors and so
there are quadrants so to speak and
you're speaking to the phenomenology of
the outlier which is that
flow with skill and Novelty and then one
last point was you talked about active
imagination
and that fits in very well with some of
the computational models in active
inference where attention is a policy
selection so it puts attention as mental
action
in the same exact formalisms that we
would use for bodily policy selection
and and uh the choosing from affordances
attention and the inner world is like
policy selection on inner Landscapes and
I think there's many angles to explore
with what does it mean to create what
does it mean to re-create what's
recreational what does it mean to member
what does it mean to remember what is
this aspect of initial generation and
what is the aspect of regeneration when
we use our generative model as a
regenerative model potentially
authenticating the observations like you
described earlier
wow that is so like yeah so beautifully
said I'm really interested in these
inner landscapes
okay yeah once I talk about uh bacon and
the BW body without organs I would love
to see what you think after that
excellent okay let's let's carry on
I love these books all right so uh I
think I briefly mentioned his Sadi
before I do think it's overlooked in the
um in like the the realm of Neurology
and maybe we should take a look at it so
um Atari quote the coin this notion of
his Sadie
um and what is this right so the hasadi
we're going to get to get you the
definition about two seconds but it's a
new take on what individuality actually
means so it's an individuality that is
devoid uh that is trying to free itself
from subjectivity so they say like
trying to be a subject sometimes that's
actually too much to ask for someone who
maybe like you know hurting or in a
state of like you know uh extreme
pressure maybe didn't do so well on
something actually requiring someone to
be a subject could be too high of a toll
and individuality
um a husseini evokes an individuality to
something less than a subject I found it
so freeing I was like can I just please
be a horse today can I please just um
you know can I be a glass of water can I
have the being and the affordances of a
glass of water and put aside the subject
just for a second I need to rest right
so this is the kind of thought process
that like happens and all of us know
that in intense academic programs you
have to kind of rest you know
um so when we talk about again the
Neuroscience of creativity
um so what what does it mean to have a
decreased activation of the sense of
self so we ask this rest of this opening
what is this sense of self and how does
it relate to the self
sense of self and how does it actually
relate to these self can you actually
parse this should we say that the self
observes this sense of self
or does this sense of self observe
itself
right and I know fep can guide us
through something like that there's not
a lot of propositions that could right
if you don't have fep you may not be
able to like fine-tune this and this
kind of dynamicism most people would
just jump right over it so these like
the reflexive play on words which is the
very ground of like priest um you know
uh logic paradoxes and and thought
paradoxes and which which she calls
limit paradoxes so anytime you put it
like a self-reference on a system you're
going to have these problems so um we we
invoke this notion of an eigen form it's
a fixed point of a recursive process and
we're going to say that like
um saying you know that you have this
this
iteration this recursion actually
generalizes the idea of an identity
operator and it's going to implement the
eternal return so we're trying to sort
of mix this reflexivity with the often
with authenticating an object and what
does that actually mean with the
internal returns so again brilliantly
says like it's the law of a world
without being without Unity without
identity
far from presupposing the one or the
same the eternal return constitutes the
only Unity of the multiple as such the
only identity of what actually differs
so coming back is the only being of
becoming and the the function of the
eternal return as being is never to
identify but to authenticate so those
two once again we are finding Two Worlds
that are colliding on the authentication
different phenomenologies so if we
conceptualize math art in all creative
activities ways of distilling experience
into meaningful and memorable summaries
or abstracts so how do you how do you
impose meaning what why does an agent
impose meaning and how external meaning
internal meaning on the internal
Landscapes so we're saying that these
are actually Technologies for preserving
useful and significant aspects of
experience over time but we we 100 say
memory is constructive it requires an
act of authentication you got to be real
careful about what's actually being
authenticated like you said earlier
member versus remember so that qualifier
is actually kind of troubling so Chris
brilliantly said the Dark Ages lost not
so much text but the ability to read
them
so we say if identification is by
definition post-hoc after the fact what
is actually being authenticated what is
this once again I think this is another
limit Paradox I'm taking the notion of
authentication and ramming it until it's
going to fall apart
so Duluth says Society is again another
mode of individuation very different
from that of a person subject thing or
substance you reserve the name has Saidi
for it a season a winter a summer an
hour a date they have a perfect
individuality lacking nothing it is not
a thing or a subject a degree of heat an
intensity of Life perfect
individualities notice this abstraction
away from the subject we talk about the
aha moment we're going to say to the aha
moment does not obey the ordinary time
of doing and happening so if there
really is no self present during the aha
moment who is experiencing anything
time without present I without I this is
nothing of which one could say that
experience a form of knowledge would
either reveal or conceal it commensure
it with it there is no faith that is
blancho powerful so we're invoking heavy
Continental philosophy at the same time
of a neurological phenomena the aha
moment so blancho is powerful they're
commensurate with that aha moment there
is no faith what is that meaning there
is nothing measurable in that moment so
we say that they'll have a time of bliss
obeys the time of has Saidi it's it's a
completely different time it's that flow
time it's sharply contrasted with the
situational time of doing and and things
to be done so we say the individual the
individuation of a life is not the same
as it is the individuation of the
subject that leads it or serves as its
support So to say anytime not it's not
in the same time the same temporality I
think this is beautifully said so Eon
it's the indefinite time of the event
it's floating it's actually it's
something that is both going to happen
it's just happened so blanchelle also
has this beautiful notion of passivity
absolutely passivity no self present to
categorize the other as a depersonal of
time of bliss it's almost as an
abdication so all of this is
self-abdication either through
mathematics or philosophy so in this
state there really is no self to Grant
the authorization to say that anything
happens if there's no self-present who's
to say that anything happens according
to that the inner world of experience
so he has this quote he says I I would
prefer not to that statement is an
abstention she never had to be decided
upon it precedes all decisions and which
is not so much a denial as more than
that an abdication I thought that was
beautiful it belongs to the
infinitiveness of patients so that sort
of hard Infinity no dialectical
intervention can take hold of such
passivity so we've Fallen outside the
world of being outside we're immobile
proceeding with a slow and even step
destroyed men come and go this is the
realm I love this realm can in this
realm can we mathematize what's going on
here with fep insights and condensed
formalism so when you get to Source
monitoring there's a sense of
uncapturable time unreportable events
occur and possibly intended but
uncontrollable actions happen and it's
forced onto Us by quantum theory quantum
theory is a beautiful theory about
non-fungible or unshareable information
now that's precisely the quantum phase
information that distinguishes an
individuate's Quantum States it enforces
a radical uniqueness onto Quantum
systems radically unique challenges the
very the very idea of fully transparent
information sharing non-fungibility so
if we use the time of the Sadie then it
puts the the reality monitoring in a new
light in our own reality we're
monitoring including our own ability to
remember and authenticate but we are
more moreover only monitoring a
simulacrum of the event itself it is is
non-fungible and unrecordable so we say
that reality monitoring becomes a
rationalizing reconstruction the form of
motivated reasoning it serves the need
for instability doesn't really exist so
the continuity of time we are hardcore
claiming that it's illusory
so let's get into the self and jump into
grothentic and airdosh this is really
fun so we bring up young and some
beautiful things that uh that young was
thinking about so the reportable self
that Shanna that you know participated
yesterday it did all the things in the
past has plans for the future the self
that has beliefs and desires and other
attitudes the self with relationships
right this is the constructed self of
memory in in words of Seth so the
reportable self the the experienced self
the I that speaks and thinks this is the
eye that directs the body it's conscious
but severe sufficiently severe
anterogrid Amnesia can almost surgically
remove the experience itself I spoke of
Clive wearing before five ring has lost
personal memory still has motor memory
we'll walk in and say I you know I I've
never seen a doctor before in my life
they visit him all the time I've never
seen a piano before in my life but can
play one
um what what sort of experience is this
Clive has about a six second memory
right where's the authentication in a
six second memory right so uh Clive you
know Clive's use of I is profoundly
different than mine so I replied using
an eye this actually has no enduring
first person subject reference and what
can we make of that so we're forming
we're going to formally distinguish this
constructed Cartesian cell from the
ungraspable self-advisity what Young is
going to call a virtual point so young
started all this virtual point it's a
virtual point on some kind of scale
between unconscious and conscious so our
interest here is in what this experience
itself is like how it how it differs so
here's the amphitheater in the a
Fantasia spectrum that I spoke about uh
earlier a lot of people live without
significant internally verbalized
thoughts now for people in Academia or
people like Daniel and I like I'm
talking to myself all the time so
imagine a world where there is no
internal like verbalized thoughts so
Zeman actually sharpened this
distinction by introducing the Fantasia
Spectrum so people at capable experience
rich multimodal imaginings on one end
people severely shed in imagination in
at least one modality on the other so we
actually write in the paper that we
ourselves the present authors are on
opposite ends of the spectrum for the
modality of vision I think Chris will
remember like pure text and mine has so
many colors in it I don't even know
what's happening so a Fantasia it
applies to all uses of the imagination
include shooting the Reconstruction of
episodic memories there are some people
who have no bylaw no biographical memory
a fantasics also experience deficits in
episodic memory the purely verbal
textbook-like episodic memories of CF
Chris Fields so curiously but dream
imagery can be preserved in a Fantastics
dream imagery can be preserved so
somehow it's the conscious attention to
imagination that is deficit and I found
that perplexing but then Chris said well
it's not really surprising conscious
attention is a competitive process who
or what wins the competition is not
voluntarily chosen so many things are
competing here so let's jump into the
body without organs so
we say if the cell for is actually a
construction what what is it what are
its identity conditions right so what
guarantees that the self that I
construct now is the same as the self I
constructed as a child as a student or
even yesterday how can we make any sense
of any proposed continuity of self over
time Chris and I are still on this right
I I am like Enchanted by the notion of
overtime what does that actually mean so
the standard idea of like a closest uh
like causal continuer like the I the I
somehow moves through something and it
doesn't really straightforwardly apply
it's claiming that I am still the
Constructor of myself
merely begs the question again so uh
maybe we could see learning or
experience generally as modifying the
cell these are either gradually or by or
by saltations which we think maybe
that's what it is so daily using Atari
posit this body without organs right
we're really going at it here so but
where they say that a body is actually
not determined not defined by the form
that it determines that determines it
nor is it actually a determinate
substance or subject
um nor is it determined by the organs
that possess it so our toe was Notorious
for waging like war against the organs
right I don't want the organs I'm
independent of them and so they don't
they Define this body without organs
which is actually trying to free itself
from the determinism and say that it's a
collectivity it's an an assembling
elements things plants animals tools
um it's not my body without organs
instead the me the me is on it
or what remains of me unalterable and
changing informed Crossing threshold so
Burrows famously wrote about this about
how um in some people a certain deficit
like functioning uh organs would just
seemingly Sprout anywhere The Crossing
threshold is really fun so it actually
the bwo proceeds without by contagion
rather than by category categorizable
identities that quote stay stratified
and so they call the three axes of
stratification organization
signification and subjectivity so these
after all the organism it's not at all
the body it's a stratum it's a stratum
on the body without organs so in
contrast to the pressure of continually
having the same self over time whatever
that actually means they offer quite the
opposite I love this this quote in the
text this is in the capitalism and
schizophrenia book so they say recycle
analysis says stop find yourself again
we should say instead let's go further
still we haven't found our body without
organs yet we haven't sufficiently
sufficiently dismantled ourselves
substitute forgetting or an amnesis
experimentation for interpretation find
your beauty be body without organs find
out how to make it most importantly they
say it has nothing to do with fantasy
there's nothing to interpret so to
losing Atari famously or trying to
overthrow ontology get rid of
interpretation which seems to classify
the very thing they're trying to free so
through the BW I made this connection
with Francis Bacon
uh which I thought was really powerful
so most people see the work and they are
like shocked at the level of the nervous
system or something like this so Prince
speaking did some wild things and Duluth
has a very beautiful book on him called
the hysteria of painting So DeLuise
views the The Becoming of painting in
the form of a logic of sensation it
functions through Hysteria by way of a
primordial pre-representative sensation
it's foundational too and over any
accessory forms that was my take on it
so Duluth claims that painting in the
sense of bacon becomes a hysteria it can
or it converts hysteria because it makes
presence immediately visible immediately
visible painting directly attempts to
release the presences beneath
representation Beyond representation the
color system itself is a sense of direct
action on the nervous system watch the
reactions people have looking at a bacon
painting if there's something what is
that and Duluth is trying to like
classify that he says this is not a
hysteria of the painter but a hysteria
of a painting so a painting hysteria
becomes art or rather with the painter
hysteria becomes painting
so in a sense where does the bwo come in
the body without organs right here well
it says painting liberates the eye from
its adherence to the organism the eye
becomes the virtually the polyvegan
indeterminate organism that sees the
body without organs as pure presence
so painting gives us eyes all over on
the ear and the stomach and the lungs
the painting actually breathes so
another piece that the loose finds in
Bacon's work is the phenomena of
autosupiah autoscopy is the phenomenal
where the body is felt under the body so
there's transitory organs that are felt
underneath the organization of the fixed
organs and he says something like it's
no longer my head but I feel myself
inside ahead I see and I see myself
inside a head is there a psychosis in
the world that might include this sort
of hysterical condition so what if we
geometrize the autoscopia right here's
where the math comes in
um Duluth calls math a monster slang and
that's probably because it can do things
like this
so the if the body
um the loose talks about
the body passing through itself to
escape itself so the body is sick of the
organization it's going to pass through
itself to escape itself and you'll see
these various points in Bacon's work in
the triptychs and things like that so it
escapes from itself through the open
mouth or the stomach or through the
throat or through the point of an
umbrella and the presence of a body
without organs underneath the organism
the presence of transitory organs under
the organic representation so again with
the bwo you are freeing um so it's
almost like the hysteria painting is
allowing the bwo to sit on side of the
color system so again Duluth is not
advocating any kind of deconstruction uh
destruction he's saying care and caution
must be exercised to produce such a I
called it a Solarium spacium of
intensities so what is salt it's not
forlorn bodies so they make this very
clear in their book They're not
advocating something destructive nothing
forlorn or
um you know bodies that have emptied
themselves or their organs he's saying
make it more Dynamic look for the point
at which they could pace efficiently and
momentarily dismantle the organization
of the organs that we call the organism
so body I claimed that a body passing
through itself was a body without organs
that became a hasadi and then
um so if you can see the body passing
through itself as a hasidi
um then you can see the body passing
through itself in the ways of Duluth
calls it like the spastics and the hyper
Aesthetics that are indicated by wiped
or scrubbed Zone again on francis's
triptychs and there's anesthetics and
paralytics by missing zones so you can
also get a phenomenal phenomenology
about what is missing in these pieces so
he says the zones are actually rhizomes
but what's really beautiful is that when
the body is indistinguishable from the
paint colors that are used to produce it
then the body actually passes through
the paint at the same time as it passes
through itself so begins form a painting
is hysteria it's actually hesiti once
again recalling that climate win season
hour
um they're not of another nature than
the things that populate them
they sleep and awaken with them so
Duluth says famously um this sentence
should be read without a pause the
animal Stalks at five o'clock
the animal stocks at five o'clock no
subject object like
um Coppola here
so I I kind of put a spin on that and I
said likewise this should be read
without a pause hysteria painting body
without organs becoming painting
becoming animal
so um we're about to jump into
gruffending air dish
maybe let's pause and see if any let's
recap bwo and uh
and then I'll get to aired ocean wrap it
up
okay I'll just add it right here hold on
a few comments just try to connect some
dots for those who are um painting along
so first authenticate
that reminded me of how we describe our
experience or indeed pleasurable
experiences as authentic and also
authenticate has a more technical
definition with cryptographic
verification so there's some
relationships with kind of lock and key
cryptographic ciphers and the Integrity
of existence
um you mentioned stratification
and you used the terms organized
signified and subjected and that made me
and you said the the body is a stratum
and I thought of Riverbanks and the body
in development does go through being a
point with a zygote and then it's uh
moving through topological and geometric
phases now it's a two layer now it's a
trilaminer disc and so we have a
stratification through development and
that's part of like the evolution of
Developmental complexity
then art as site kind of disassembling
but embracing this D pointing
de-literalization or something of the
point and seeing performance art and all
are as performance but the locus of
performance kind of like the cloud of
the performance is the sights it's like
you have to go to the show you have to
be there it's about the experience and
then even a type of Aesthetics like
fashion there's like the narrative that
comes along with the t-shirt that might
look the same but then when somebody has
a different Quantum reference frame or
aesthetic reference frame it can mean a
lot more and then just the last
interesting point was that
escape from autoscopia
is quite an interesting
idea and um should we pursue how should
we pursue why would we pursue such
approaches just because we can
drive off the road or drive off one road
or turn right or turn left or take off
these affordances
that cognitive entities have
how should they be regarded and selected
as to not imperil
oneself if that is even something to be
avoided
oh wow okay I can't really talk about
that one more yeah escaping autoscopia
or autoscopia and like flipping it
internalizing that even more
um yeah this is excellent okay let's see
if we get if we can link all of that
with comparing two mathematical Giants
undeniably cloth and Deacon erdosh so
there is a field Mentalist that recently
tried to um again you don't want to
classify anybody but they seem to follow
different tracks whereas eredosh is more
of a problem solver right Problem Solver
leaving
um you know like little Jewels like I'll
pay you if you can solve this et cetera
et cetera et cetera right rampant
publishing so many papers and things
like that versus goth indeed laying
heavy heavy Foundation I'm not sure was
concerned again I would have loved to
meet him to have met him but um
um I know not not particularly concerned
with problem solving but Theory building
Theory Builder right I can't even list
everything right so um
when we we juxtapose we're saying which
self and which time do these two
mathematical Giants actually obey and
where's the creativity involved in this
again we are going to be infusing math
and art into all of this uh both of
these different fields are wildly
created Eros again Super Famous Problem
Solver um and like kind of more
peripatetic
um you know kind of traveling everyone
knows these sort of eccentricities of
traveling around and you would actually
have the host a range where he was
supposed to go next could cook for him
and things like this you can play the
different from growth Indy could
literally left like an erasing an
abdication so let's talk about these in
a little more detail
um again we're just going by like
references neither one of us have met
these people so um eridocious famous for
saying you don't have to believe in God
but you should believe in the book
so the book is this uh his a met his uh
he actually believed that there was a
book that contained the most elegant
theorems and expressions
and we say what can we make of this sort
of he treats the self as it's purely as
its mathematical value
self is mathematical by you through his
belief in the book of divination
containing the most elegant proofs and
theorems literally according to like the
life I think according to erdosh was in
its mathematical value that's it right
how many things can I publish uh what
can I do he is famous for stopping
um the use of like an amphetamine or
something like this and uh for like for
a month because his friends were worried
about him and anyway so he famously says
you know you've held mathematics back
because you stopped me right uh I I
looked at the blank paper like an
ordinary person
that's what he says right so um it's
it's a little ruthless you know but it
says like you held me back I looked at
the paper like an ordinary person and
this is all in the autobiography and
it's also in the paper we talk about it
so young quote Saint Paul famously and
he says
yet not I live
but Christ liveth in me
so we asked did erdogs not lived but the
book levith in erdosh
I think that's one of our most profound
statements in this paper
let's jump to grothendiq
gothendig was after
um he actually writes about what he says
as a profound symbiosis between the hand
that writes and the spirit or thought
and of the creative act as the
archetypal Act of the human spirit
so by stating something like that there
is a thought to believe that groffendig
was aware of Young's work
and this is very reminiscent of the
actual virtual point
so you know gothindeek um you know does
not attend like the fields medal
ceremony grows up stateless it's a
completely different like uh being in a
completely different relationship with
self so we say what can we make of his
literal disappearance so being into ihes
you know he was a heavily anti-like the
military funding and stuff like that
um but literally just left right left
and said like what can we actually make
of that literal disappearance can we in
particular see Roth and D C and Groff
and Deek's concept of a site which is
again I haven't defined that it's a
category with an apology on it
um very particular topology on it can we
see in gruffendig's concept of a site
um
is that an abstraction of a point an
urge to grasp the virtuality and
dislocation that young ascribes to the
self
so what is that you know is that an
actual way of grasping the virtuality
and dislocation that young ascribes to
the self
how do you go from topos Theory
um laying the wigs for a beautiful work
in like a telecomology algebraic
geometry uh
um you know growth indeed group laying
the matter for K Theory all this stuff
to a question that haunted grothendiq
which was what is a meter
what is a meter you have a very very
technical definition of what is a meter
people I think have been kind of harsh
with him and said something like oh well
at that point he just lost his mind I'm
like is that what happened you know is
there a possibility that like what is
the time of Mind laws can we be a little
more gentler with that you know so you
know you go from topo's Theory to like
you know a complete hermit existence
after that
so closing thought that we have to ask
is about the limit Paradox and we say
we are left by the above not with an
entity wrapped in a Markov blanket but
with an imagined entity wrapped in an
imagined blanket
so we see a Quantum reference frame
specifies a semantics so hints in the
limit in which two agents fully share a
common semantics and hence a Common
Language they no longer have separate
identities
language itself becomes paradoxical
information is nonetheless shareable
although
unfungible
Communications exist this text exists
you reading it exists the meaning you
ascribe to it exists most importantly
contradiction
indeed a true contradiction a dialethia
a limit Paradox so we say such paradoxes
arise wherever there is self-reference
and it shows how science applied to
itself generates these limit paradoxes
so indeed creative Acts
are limit paradoxes
we can go like uh you know the the model
that we construct I want to like
formally finish there but um everyone
can find there's more information about
the the very like empirical model that
we Define our most important theorem is
that an entropic categorization is a
condensed set so we talk about like the
phenomenology of categorizing you know
events places things people memories and
you know we call uh time is actually
entropic because there is a flow of
information that it values um learning
over forgetting so once you have a
disruption in this flow of learning
versus you know versus uh forgetting
um it's something like an Alzheimer's or
something like this and is time no
longer entropic in that case
so that's why we call these
categorizations entropic and we're going
to say that this is condensed set so our
famous prediction is that human
retrospective and prospective memory are
implemented by what are we we're going
to call chiefification functors from a
single Pro atel site so it's a site with
a weekly Adele topology on it and it so
again we're saying that monitoring the
event-dependent phenomena through sites
is the way that you know
um is a better way of monitoring
continuity quote over time so we're
going to say if that's correct then we
expect to find no persistent neural
representation of either past or future
events only mechanisms we're
constructing
instantaneous representations
yeah then I think I just talk about that
yeah why his Sadie and the questions and
yeah so again you know can like sites
you know reframe authentication daily
theistically and
if you do have this like overtime kind
of thing what time is that you know
great okay so I'll stop there
or stop like the formal thing there to
begin a discussion if you wanted that
I'll pause there in time that I will
pause there then then I then I will
pause somewhere yeah
and that's what that's the beauty of it
it's like
you know you can trip over reality right
but as you zoom in
it's very curious as to what is like
what is holding all that together
and it's very curious that the physicist
is working on that you know dive pretty
heavily into Eastern thinking or you've
Groff and degrading young you know like
trying to figure this stuff out
I don't know what what do you think
would have a take on a
juxtaposing these vastly different
ways of existing and interpreting their
worlds right
I wanted to pick up there and then of
course we'll just see where we go and
anyone who's watching may also add
questions so
the
juxtaposition of growth indic and erdosh
was very interesting
and you described growthendig as a
theory Builder and erdosh as a problem
solver and that seemed to map back into
that type 1 type 2 space
like type 1 intuition is problem solving
it's like the thing is falling off the
table and there's a reflexive response
to solve the problem even before there's
a theory of the problem or someone is
skiing and they're able to use their
body and extended cognitive apparatus
and skill and all of this to solve
problems that aren't even stated in
contrast the development of theory and
generalizations and to codify
is a a case
Independence process you're solving a
ton of problems you're solving every
problem of a nail needing to be hit
the hammer solves above any specific
nail but also it solves no specific nail
and um that I felt like was very
illustrative and spoke to potentially
other
continua of
doing and thinking
what do you think about that yeah yeah
just again it brings me back to this
like Saint Paul like beautiful quote
yeah not I love it but Christ liveth in
me so that also seems uh
that's tricky I'm not sure if that's
like case independent right yeah it's
almost like uh
I like that solving the problem before
there exists a theory of the problem
that's tricky
that's tricky uh
and you know the the question is like
what is the sense of self of a problem
solver and versus a theory solver do you
have to have a uh less tethered sense of
self to be a theory Builder because
you're trying to figure out for all
possible males
and that's I think that's I think uh
I think a lot of mathematicians do that
right because it's just all about the
nobody really cares if you're well or
not it's sort of just like did you Ace
this exam
did you Ace his exam did you finish the
theorem did you do all of this and so
everybody knows you know the reason
there's a lot of like you know mental
health like scares in fields like that
is because nobody really asks how you
are
so I'm wondering if all the ideas about
how is Shanna is she eating today she's
sleeping oh you have to push it aside
now look at all the pressure that Gotham
digs under you have to push all the like
growth indic aside to be an abstraction
to create these theories
to create these theories let me put the
self aside
in order to create that many theories
versus somebody like erdosh I don't
think was particularly deeply emotional
about these things or something but you
know gothindeak had a lot there was a
lot there and it's notorious in his like
you know 800 page letters to people
right something like who is he writing
for who is he writing for he dipped out
does not want to be found so there's a
nice website that kind of like talks
about like last interactions some a few
mathematicians kind of saw him so they
opened the door and the look was sort of
like you know I don't want to be found
so what can you make of that like I
don't want to be found yet I'm going to
be writing
profound volumes right I don't even
think what do you I don't even think
that's a self that it's interesting to
not want to be found
but to continue to write
who's who's the writing for when it is
still in this sort of like
epistolary form who's he writing to
so it's almost like again like you had
to get rid of all the emotionality or
put it somewhere else which makes me
think of like any mathematician is
skilled on that that young sort of line
between conscious and unconscious and
the self being like a point on it
you know a lot of mathematicians will
identify as heavily
um you know Autistic or something like
this right and why is that something
that helps the mathematics
is it because your mind was free of the
emotional turmoil of being of subject of
something like this you know it's you
know it's really sad you could you know
what if you had like something emotional
happened to you everybody knows you're
not going to be able to perform very
well in a math test so what what is that
what is it that the theorem's like are
trying to Trump the emotionality or
something like that so you almost have
to be in this monk state
probably or have a life that does not
have a bunch of peril in it to do well
on these theorems and so what do you
think about that like to do some of
these like hardcore Sciences maybe you
have to put the self aside or you
abstract it I don't know
well a few things there it seems related
to Maslow's hierarchy of needs and
indeed the um higher order though higher
and lower is just a spatial metaphor
um it's possible for someone to be
having the worst emotional day of their
life but their blood pressure is
regulated and there are complex
feedbacks the way one feels can
influence their physiology and vice
versa but then zooming out to the level
of the researcher involved in theory
building as well as the problem solver
involved in applications like kind of
research and practice that is enabled by
the physiology of society
and so it is um a scaffolded work that
can influence the whole you you
mentioned the
um epistolary nature of growth and
Dick's writing which means in the form
of letters and that's quite a connection
not just to the Bible and certain books
of the Bible which are written as
letters but also to this
emergence of art as sight
if the art is a letter a letter is to
someone someone could write a letter to
themself in the future or it could be
like a letter who's kind of ironic
performativity is that it's to no one or
it's two
um some imaginary character but the
genre and the format of art that is a
letter
is
needing to be mailed and it has to be
opened and read and so I think the
letter is like a very plain text
performance art
yeah that's really beautiful because
again you know there's like some sad
things that occur by letter two right so
some things it's interesting it's
interesting that it's like let me write
this let me deliver it to you so that
I'm not there when you open it
right it can take you know that's like
the nature of surprise or maybe like a
partner leaving somebody you know you
hear these horrible stories right all
right suicidal thing like I left a note
it's interesting that that the letter
writing yeah what is that I like that
needed to be mailed I love that you know
there's like photos of the place that he
was at like in France just in the I
don't know the I think the population's
like 150 it's tiny and uh volumes
volumes
like it's like male to whom
and what's In Our Mail system I don't
think this is like you know Hedwig
sending sending it by Al or something
but it's almost like
I don't know and that's why we were
fascinated by that because you go from
someone who already excelled in
everything but had a very harsh
upbringing into that world they all say
that they're like you know this isn't
like the normal person that comes to
like a you know mathematical like place
and so in one sense like you know I like
that I like that it gave him more
whereas some people saw him as so
strange I was like maybe that's why you
know he did so much you know because he
came in with something different and um
you know you could also say that he was
just sick of sort of the the bureaucracy
of everything but you know we you know
are like lost mind and Chris and I were
like maybe there's something deeper
there can we be more gentle to someone
in a state like that you know
so I like this needing to be mailed I
have no idea anything a lot of
mathematical working in Robert lands I
could say Mr Johnny Orlando's program by
writing a letter as well but it didn't
have this same like depth to it you know
so grothink was on something else which
is why I really relate because he's
always about the philosophy in there you
know I've often been perplexed I
remember really whenever I learned like
you know acceleration or something per
second per second
it's like what is that and then you can
do it again for a second per second per
second and it's like you know what are
these fundamental units uh Becca talks
about that in a lot of his work as well
so we're really perplexed that you know
that Chris and I are able to slide
around like we know who we are in a
sense but we're not tied to something
and we're open that we ourselves can be
able to uh intersect I think these heavy
ideas and look at like look at these
grandiose personalities
from such a different space
I was like yeah there's Theory building
but again like you know when you mail a
letter indefinitely is it a message in a
bottle that only somebody will read
and you know this kind of different it's
like is it a male is it a letter
addressed to someone
or is it just addressed you know to the
fact that Quantum mechanically it'll be
opened at some point you know
all right a few interesting thoughts
here very early you said thoughts and
then you quoted an author and you said
the paragraph begun with at any rate you
have them well rate is what something
through time so even that uh just
turn a phrase speaks to time and then
is the self a theory well it does
theorize about certain things and that
was related to self and the sense of
self is the self a problem to be solved
is the self a solution to a problem
so where in the growth indic erdosh
type 1 type 2 space is self
self-ass problems self-ass solution
theory of self as problem theory of self
as solution
I love that
oh wow maybe that's the open-endedness
because I know some of the math stuff
stopped and then he was just like
Enchanted by this notion of meter light
speed of light and things like this you
know and uh I don't know there's been a
lot of like cool work about
different physical theories about like a
non- a variational speed of light and
things like that you know
um or like primordial black holes so
there was like you know Armenia is girl
I think just really alone was there like
whoa you know you you have to think
about things like that you know if you
had a collaborator or somebody to talk
to you like you or me would that have
changed something I don't know I don't
know you have to think about like is the
abdication
yeah is the abdication a problem or a
solution
I'm not sure I'm really not sure you
know so but again like you know go ahead
don't the solutions one day turn into
problems tomorrow through time see
through time
at any rate you have them
no idea you know yeah and again we all
know that to be high level functioning
like you know someone like you and I are
people watching this able to like follow
this thread
um you have like we are able to function
so Chris told me that very well I'm
highly imaginative Super Hyper uh
fantastic right and yet I'm like
extremely functional extremely
functional so we all know that deficit
functioning can start plaguing
um you know certain people like uh
diagnosis schizophrenics or something
like this that are actually unable to
recognize the internal thoughts
as their own thoughts you know and so uh
sometimes neurology can be a little like
not so kind with something like that and
say oh you're unable to recognize the
inner voice as your own remember I asked
Chris that a couple times I was like
Chris whenever we're sitting there
thinking to ourselves like uh who is
that who is that that you're actually
talking to and he said Shanna just open
like speak whenever that thought is
there whenever the internal thoughts are
there just open and speak sure enough it
was the same speaking voice that was
inside
and I thought okay so that that's that's
not as Mystic as I thought but somehow
if you're unable to Source Monitor and
reality monitor that like what does that
actually mean you know so in the case of
like deficit functioning or something
like that with these like you know with
schizophrenics then you have to think
um
like how can you slowly reintroduce
noticing the inner self to an extent
that doesn't like blast apart the you
know the current self if that makes
sense you know it must be kind of scary
to say
oh well there's another person inside of
me that thinks like this or okay that's
not the other person that thinks like
this it's actually me I'm just not
recognizing the other axes of me like
you kind of said earlier
so I think you know you either have to
be very chill with the fact that you
have so many systems running at the same
time or you're hyper aware like Chris
and I are and you're functional with it
because I think if you're hyper aware
and you're non-functional then you're
not going to be able to leave the
hyper-fantastic world and like save your
child you have to come back right so
people like John Nash and things like
this again you know math and physics
will do this to people because there's
it's such a pressure cooker such a
pressure cooker and again I think you
have to put the self aside or something
like that which needs to be dealt with
but at a certain point you know the
hallucinations like do occur and you
know John Nash is like literally seeing
people right so and that famous like
scene in A Beautiful Mind where he's
like oh I'll watch you know I can give
the baby a bath and you know the baby is
like almost drowning and the wife you
know runs in his wife runs in and you
know she's like what happened he goes
well Charles is taking you Charles is
taking care of the child you know so for
me it's like
I'm interested in this can you be an
excellent mathematician on this scale of
golf and you can Earnest and still care
for your child
can you swing back to the actual conch
if you're a virtual point if you have to
quote Focus right people say I need to
get rid of distraction so I can focus
can you actually focus and then go save
your child right like this would be a
sense of self what do you think about
that then you're like I'm I'm able to
recognize my inner thoughts I'm not
going to be pushed to a deficit
functioning right I'm going to be able
to recognize what is real and what is
not I'm not going to let hyper Fantasia
tilt my complete access but I'm going to
be able to come back and be able to go
fully to the imaginary space and come
back and take care of my family or stop
at that red light like what do you think
about that
well a few things I'll respond to that
and then two other areas that were going
to be touching upon are art visual art
and history of philosophy just kind of
planting that so as to the is it
possible to be functional and
imaginative
in the context of
uh deficits
what if we flipped it and said it's a
surplus of free energy
and the lack of the deficit is the
Surplus
and so that just does this kind of
minimum maximum inversion that happens
so often in the fep and then also
um with this again type 1 to type two
problem solving to Theory building air
Dosh to growthentic axis that we're
working with it seems like both of them
in a social cultural context can be
aligned with service or not someone can
develop Theory or they can ruminate on
Theory and have a um failure to serve
and although some mathematicians and
there's a particular mode with Academia
and everything as we know it today where
people might be obsessed with a proof
and that leads them to neglect the bath
water somebody else might be thinking
about free throws in their head or they
might be
practicing their other skill and so
there's different modes of
rumination
that might be just for different people
in different situations look more
professional technical academic or might
be which is Theory building
or closer to problem solving and thus
resemble more of a mechanical obsessive
compulsive
situation
to art
well in the title of this paper
there's of course the creative and fun
portmanteau of math art
and also the paper
situates itself as describing the period
from 1920 to the present now I guess
it's always the present
that's why they call it the gift
um but we can just take it as 2022. so
what happens from 1920 to 2022 why 1920
as a beginning and could you mention any
movements in Aesthetics or are
impressionism cubism pointillism all
these just different schools of Art and
fads and hype Cycles
what has happened since 1920 and how
does that relate to your deeper stances
yeah so again we're just seeing that
through line that you know
of of elimination abstraction
reification
uh like yive's Klein Blue on Blue
right where do you go after that where
do you go after white on white
and so I think we're saying
you have endless places to go through
white on white
so
instead of just giving up and saying
that you know once you've abstracted
everything to a point
I think that's where it's almost like
uh it's like it's like a seesaw or
something where art you know thought it
was maybe kind of done math swooped in
and said you know what what is the point
what is a point what is color
why don't we try to create dark colors
right so we all know that you know dark
energy and things like those are what 90
of this place
baryonic matter is like such a small
percentage
so you have a light spectrum you know
that I don't know that white light is
Prismatic
what about dark colors
you know
since dark energy does not interact
electromagnetically with matter could we
create a dark energy equivalent of a
cover color wheel
you know the color of wheel looks like
the circle of fifths so I think there's
like a lot of places for you know
uh white on white to push through
towards when you start questioning what
is white what is things like this so
we're saying that like through that
abstraction through the dissolution of
the self
if you're going abstract it away you
have to really talk about what the self
is if you think you have abstracted it
away you really need to talk about what
the self is and so I think
what we've done is shown that through
20s right with data and all this kind of
stuff you know Advent of like quantum
mechanics and things like that huge
explosion on all kinds of Realms that I
think you could be guided by a couple
things limit paradox
limit Paradox right the IDE the nature
of self-reference
you know even when you have something as
anesthetic a term as self-reference what
is this self
so I think uh what math is going to do
is ask Art to
please ask what is self and can you take
these two lines
can you draw from a virtual point what
does yelling have to do with the
intersection of math art
is math art an inevitable consequence
and that's what Chris and I are kind of
like
alluding to
that you have to join them possibly to
get out of white on white
join them together let them merge forces
and then you can start mathematizing
autoscopia and figuring out different
spaces
right so like if a point is no like how
do you define a point like a zero
dimensional object or something like
that but if you re-identify point as a
growthendiq site then you have actually
infused a new set of Infinities into
that point so Chris and I are advocating
for if you think you've done it if you
think you've gotten rid of the self if
you think white on white if you think
you've just
squished everything to a point or
something like that well the gothentic
notion of a site and category theory is
going to always allow morphisms and ways
out
so I think it's kind of cool that like
you know in the vein of like Duluth we
should follow to lose in guitari uh
through this work of his Sadie try to
invoke a mathematization of society and
then you can see something like body
passing through itself like I think art
can always go further go through white
on white what does that actually look
like you know like create create the
white hole create quote on the other
side create all sides at once I know I
always do this thought experiment of
like you know what if I could draw an
object from 360 degrees or what if I
could be
you know
or like you know if you want to proceed
by the way of like limit paradoxes why
is it that every day I wake up and I'm
the same you know I'm not like a lobster
or something like that so these kind of
thought experiments I think can like I
don't know if I don't know if what I
said makes any sense but does that make
any sense that you can push through this
and that maybe possibly math art is like
a necessary emergence or does math art
become the space of affordance you have
such great ideas what do you think of
any of that stuff
well
to return to this historical
dance and interplay with philosophy art
and math
I'm reminded of the development of
perspectival drawing
in the let's just say latter half of the
1000s Millennia where there's a few
points there's the vanishing point
that's like the classic you know on the
horizon you draw the string and all the
buildings go towards it
and then there's also the the point of
perspective and there's like the light
point source and there's the center of
gravity and all of these complexities
relational complexities
do play into that Zero Dimensional Point
concept
if we have a rich Point concept
like to point at perhaps to point out a
locus of action or to use a Point
concept like that from Bucky Fuller's
synergetics where a point is just a
tetrahedra that you're seeing as a speck
but it's a geometry of lumps and so you
have space packing of finite actual
space enclosed shapes and a point is
just one that you're really far away
from it's outside of your kind of tuned
into it
then there's
more richness
and there's also a an inherent
plurality in those points
whereas the vanishing point and the
Cartesian Observer it's
[Music]
um
it's narrow
and then that leads to potentially a
narrow
or fragile or over fit self
for whom even small changes can be
extremely troubling
whereas if the self is more like a swarm
or a locus of action then certain
phenomena that might be more troubling
potentially up to and including death
are more naturally
part of the becoming of that Locus
rather than
the cessation of a point yeah
I love that and then from the nature of
authentication it's itself is multiple
so I completely agree with you on that
there is nothing fixed in a swarm can
more quickly be able to respond react
can like Theory perhaps Theory building
will lead us to the self to be multiple
in a swarm I agree uh with the ability
for each point in this form
act act act act act act
so it could lead to a crescendo of
actions I agree I know in like you know
in really really beautiful like martial
art training or something teach you to
be ready
be ready be open because if I'm sitting
here like waiting for somebody to come
this way and somebody comes behind I'm
already lost
be open be Omni right
so I think that's like yeah it's a
different state it's a different state
so Theory building I think absolutely
relates with swarm thinking and swarm
multi
so if point is multi then point is able
to engage
with with more things yeah I agree and I
think that's what site is doing so
instead of having a
like a final point this is like the
final Point uh you know she Theory and
stuff like that is going to say above
every point you actually have things
that collapse down to the point so it's
no longer even about the point it's
about taking the inverse image of the
point and seeing what lives like
upstairs and hopefully that that's what
never ends
yeah so a point more is Portal I think
is what I'm more interested in you know
or self is Portal something like that
yeah versus in this this finitude I am
this I am this
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's um
how we end sentences with a point so it
does have a finitude a few more art
comments Kandinsky the artist had works
that considered for example point and
line to plane which looked at some
complexity of geometry and topology on
the plane
and um also wrote concerning the
spiritual in art
and spoke of an outer sound and an inner
sound and I think that is kind of
pre-saging this like
dark matter of colors like aren't colors
defined by their visuality it's like
well yes and matter is defined by its
interactivity with other matter yet
under those calculations most of it
isn't even doing that
so what is the inner color
such that even though we know that the
printed image or the computer screen is
only displaying one RGB value what is it
that allows you to look at
someone's cheek and see depth
and how does that
sort of
inner
sound and inner color
relate to the letter being received
yeah I agree and I do think Duluth
helped Harold that while that book is
not written in the 1960s but like the
you know I mean
like wherever he says the you know
painting as hysteria so I agree it gives
that sort of a
uh
it's no longer about the color the color
passes through at the same time so
there's um uh levels of becoming so the
the brush stroke right becomes uh an
antiseptic or a like a a form of
abdication body leaving at this at the
same time that the smear or the brush
stroke right leaves color so color
becomes representation uh I becomes
polyvalent and that's the kind of thing
that I think um with respect to what you
said that Duluth can can give us that so
Kandinsky you know saying you know inner
sound outer sound and to lose I think
would completely agree and point to
something like Francis Bacon whose work
is defying that subject object relation
so you just see like a scream right a
lot of his figures just have open mouths
and things like that so you're just
seeing the intensity of it without the
subject object Coppola and for some
sense there's an immediacy in that like
there is an aha so so the sense of the
screen is definitely not I don't think
it's at the same time as like I paid my
rent today right I you know so it's um
it's at the level of ghastly which
whatever that is so that's why Chris and
I are saying that all works are you know
uh creative like whatever type they are
in the proportion of like true
provocativeization right so here I am
here's a work of art I'm going to like
take away your continuity of subject
object to Coppola and I'm going to make
it a hysteresis
and I'm going to put eyes everywhere
eyes everywhere so that leads into again
like
multiple swarm swarm thinking you know
you put eyes in your head you know what
I mean eyes everywhere and so I like
what you say like it's not about RGB
um
it's not about RGB and you have to think
about people like uh how does Clive
wearing see color
so I think we need to be really careful
about these sort of like molar
structures color is this and and
rephrase that as to what color could be
when it leaves like circle of fists or
when it leaves this or merge color with
something else you know have another
like synesthetic experience and what is
that
um
yeah so I think uh Duluth did that
really well of taking these ideas and
actually noticing in Bacon's work like a
symptomology a symptomology oh this is a
symptom of Hysteria right and not
hysteria again like not hysteria of the
like painter but hysteria painting
itself so I think it's very cool to give
Life Force to the painting and a lot of
painting itself to become but it you
can't like fix it so I like how he says
that it's like he has this whole book
about uh becoming Sorcerers and things
like that and so he was like a Critic a
Critic of Freud sometimes for reducing
everything people would come to him with
severe problems and he would say oh it's
because a dad issue or something like
that so it always like localizes
um versus having like poly vegan organs
everywhere you know something like that
yeah right I'll give some comments and
I'll read a very nice quotes from Ali in
the chat so what that made me think
about is
the hunter is an identity
hunting is a process that's happening in
time but the hunt
the game
the forage those are more of these um
hasades they exist abstracted from the
process and from the identity though we
may linguistically symbolize it
um so I'll read some quotes that all
these added these are um I think
bringing a lot of depth to the
pieces you've raised so
recur returning earlier to discussion of
problem and problem solving so this is
from Jeffrey Bell in inquiry into
analytic Continental metaphysics and the
quote is a problem is a non-maryological
parts and holes non-merological part of
its solution meaning a part that cannot
be separated and detached from that of
which it is a part
and this is a part moreover that is not
exhausted by the determinant solution of
which it is apart
and I think in terms of the history of
philosophy and then feel free to add any
comments we can contrast this problem
concept theory of problems growth and
dig on air Dosh and we can contrast this
enmeshed relationship of problem and
solution
with a
classical
hegelian dialectic of the sequential
nature problem
solution consequence or other ways to
State the hegelian dialectic but that is
often framed in time
as like first there's a reaction then
there's a counter reaction then there's
a synthesis as opposed to this
instantaneous assemblage concept of
problem and solution in which they're
all coexisting and so therefore the
seeds of the solution are in the problem
and vice versa now rather than through
time only and maybe both are
applicable
yeah I like that
um yeah thank you for these beautiful
quotes I do love uh I always tend to
respect everyone for trying so
everybody's trying these theories and
you know I myself always had a problem
with it's like okay uh you know nature
of the problem like thesis antithesis or
whatever and then uh synthesis so I
jumped right into adorno's negative
dialectics I thought that was really
powerful because an adorno's thinking
you know like that synthesis
don't let the synthesis hurt the
multiplicity
and so it's like can you have
thesis and antithesis and then have a
synthesis that doesn't destroy both
that's why we think the nature of this
is to go through dialethism imagine a
beautiful world where you could have a
and not a existing
and this is why I think people wouldn't
hurt each other so much you know or
wouldn't like make these harsh comments
like oh they lost their mind or
something like this and it's like maybe
they're in this dual State maybe it is
the state of you know Shanna wants a
banana but she also doesn't
so I think the way out of this is going
to be kind of Hefty and it's going to be
through merging these two beautiful
quotes that were just spoken can you
merge these in a way that doesn't lose
them both right that's the nature we've
been struggling with for a long time the
nature of conflict could it be to uh
lessen the conflict by going the
dilithiistic way through negative
dialectics
can you actually do that
what kind of a space
what kind of a new affordances would you
actually need to be able to hold both
States
and I think that's possibly that's where
we're getting could you be the
growthentic air could you have you know
Hegel and adorno actually in a room
talking to each other and what does that
actually mean
um I we just need to always be quick to
not mute or take away you know the voice
of someone who possibly cannot speak
no so uh to just say deficit functioning
is what's causing these things like can
you actually can we hold Clive can we
like hold that space
uh and I think in the nature of these
two quotes I'm reminded of a Clive a
quote that Clive said where they asked
him uh where is home I've spoken about
this before and he says home is
yesterday
so I found this doubly perplexing
because here's someone whose concept of
time is six seconds
Clive doesn't even have a yesterday
according to my sort of Western thinking
but yet he says home as yesterday
and Clyde is not an invalid there's
something actually here
so I think you know to say thesis
antithesis synthesis
you could be excluding the synesthetes
or somebody hyper Fantasia like me that
can at the same time see problem like
can see all of them at once and it
becomes like almost unbearable you know
so what kind of mindset are we valuing
when we value like someone who can
actually see see thesis what about for
someone who they all happen at the same
time
and so that's like in the synesthetic
realm
um I think we not to need to not exclude
that let us not exclude that but also
with regards to those two quotes you
have somebody like Bard saying if you're
really going to have like a synthesis
please make sure it is not
anti-frastical and that we are not lying
right please make sure you're not saying
that you support something which you
actually aren't you know don't try to
support the voice that you're
diminishing at the same time
so I agree how do we how do we hold
affordances that will lead to a swarm a
very Dynamic agent a dynamic agent that
is a
um
that is capable of becoming
cable becoming and not lost in it let us
not find nihilism in the limit Paradox
that's the beauty of math that's why I
think math and art can really help each
other because mathematicians will just
like oh you're telling me there's no
solution to x squared is negative 25
well I'll invent I you know what I'll go
up a dimension and so that's what I
think we need to do to logic can we add
another dimension to logic can we
actually work in dialecticism how can we
do that you know can we add another axis
on painting art is Art is wild with that
can we add another axis of creation can
we try to paint from 360 Degrees can we
imagine everything from All Points of
View like that would be a purely Omni
existence right I had a discussion it
turned out to a kind of a feud with a
friend who I mean I don't like losing
things and it's very hard on me
um so um like people or you know animals
and things like that it makes me very
sad but it was like um uh you know I was
like I wish everything was infinite and
he actually challenged me that I
wouldn't be able to handle hard Infinity
because he said even the horrible memory
would last forever and things like this
so is there a way for us to like
put the thought and the spacing so
you're able to handle these things that
were possibly infinite infinite
becomings and things like that without
dipping the infinity into like nihilism
you know
thank you for their quotes they just
spawned all of that you know
could you describe what
thile aesthetic means and how it's used
here
yeah so um uh so dialethism is a logic
that removes the law of the excluded
middle so if everybody knows this like I
always find first order logic very
limiting to creatures such as vivasis as
us
so the excluded middle says something
like you know P or Q not P therefore Q
I thought this was so incredibly like
boring and limiting and like what you're
assuming that uh I am not multi-sentient
I'm not a multiplicity and then I'm
definitely not a synesthe you know so
diolethism is going to replace that and
say you can have a logic of the
structure such as P or Q not P therefore
p
so I think it is completely
revolutionary and it's a very it's a
nice logic that would be fit quantum
mechanics and things like this right it
is the very nature of having a parallel
universe so if you do believe many
worlds
um which I think most people have to
with these days unless you pause it an
infinite Observer then you are
guaranteed the existence that at every
mode of uncertainty there is no collapse
of the wave function everything is
realized how do you do that in a
language
the language would have to be daily
theistic you'd have to replace the law
of excluded metal with something like oh
Shanna chose like the pink sweater to
wear for the talk today like instead of
the blue the instead of also has its own
reality but the ontological status of
that is very beautifully like questioned
by Chalmers and all these amazing people
and so uh the dilethism would actually
be able to give you pink sweater and not
pink sweater and so I think so like
Chris and I being trained in that are
able to hold these very
interdisciplinary papers if you know me
I'm such an advocate for like can we
please design like a universal Institute
where like you know Daniel me Chris
everybody's in a room thinking artists
mathematicians like physicists so
there's there's Excellence to be to
being the problem solver just in with
respect to your discipline but can we
open this a little bit and become more
Theory Builders so I think that um by
merging you know the I think you have to
have a different mindset something like
me and Chris that are open to the sort
of P you know that this is natural to
our language to say both p and not p
then we're capable of writing these very
heavily interdisciplinary papers you do
find some people that are like I don't
think I'd be able to work
interdisciplinary because my field is
this
well why don't we merge them you know
and if merging leads to contradiction
and that means our definitions weren't
good enough right like math people love
Paradox and uh you know limit paradoxes
it's like let me do better let me try a
little harder let me make that
definition just a little better uh Point
leads to like UV Infinities I don't like
this thing I'm going to make a string
and make a string on registering that
might help you know what a string I
don't know and so there's this wild aha
intuition driving all the physics they
are very very you know all the hard
Sciences are very heavily trained so
we're saying like don't lose the AHA and
it's perhaps the AHA join with the
technique that's actually doing
something like this so again if you
could that's what diolethism means and
so in this case right uh the
dilethiistic work is that you have both
a painting of color but you also have an
autoscopy at the same time it seems like
those would actually tear apart the
notion of form but it's like you have
this notion of underneath right
so diolethism is questioning whatever
you're calling the level of awareness
and like you know fundamental units of
life so you know take it you know sick
people and Comas and things like that
like sometimes they can still hear you
it's like let us not be so hierarchical
about the fundamental unit of life you
know and so if you can open yourself
then you can have like
I don't know maybe Chris and I are just
trying to get quantum mechanics like
more in the macro State and then you
have like you know dialysis and stuff
but I'm also more gentle because I know
it's hard you're like no I want that no
I don't
that's like the basis of like very human
existence right I would love that but I
wouldn't
you know so we're it's like we are those
kind of creatures you know so uh we're
just trying kind of like uh Deluge is
doing with hysteria and saying that
painting releases the presence
underneath representation Chris and I
are trying to write interdisciplinary
Works to release the dialethism beneath
um
this sort of silo-ness
you know
well
thanks just a comment and then some some
more great uh please yeah from live chat
so
if there is a unitary Cartesian Observer
perspectival drawing world that we're in
then it's not even really an excluded
middle it's just either in one place or
the other
whereas the Swarm the assemblage must be
in multiple places and so it can be
wearing the pink sweater and the blue
sweater
yes as a Quantum multiple worlds yes as
an imaginary counterfactual and in
embodiment and so that's why the
assemblage can do things now that even
the most advanced processor can't do in
series
yes
let me add some more great um comments
from the chat so Ian from innersense
this was referring to your desire and or
not for a banana
holding both States
taking the awareness of being in two
minds about whether I want a banana or
not and applying that to Global issues
and group sense making so multi-scale
holding space and then also
um Ali has added several comments which
I won't read all of them about different
spaces and Metric spaces and also noted
Corey Shores the logic of Guiles to lose
discussion discusses dialethism at
length in the context of delusion
thought yes
yay the logic of sense yeah that's like
one of my favorites oh what a what a
what a beautiful audience
we should all write papers together
in our in our
closing sections
where do we go what do we do or what are
next steps
yeah next steps we go everywhere so
Chris and I are working on that like
like that you know that if we could just
get this theorem like you know an
entropic categorization as a condensed
set then all in that one sentence we're
saying time is entropic it's still
Dynamic and we're saying that like
um making like but it's not what we
think it is if we can get an event
independent uh an event-dependent logic
an event-dependent notion of time to
make time itself be this multiplicity
then we're actually going to have like a
way to mathematize where maybe other
fields stopped so where I think where we
go there's so many places to go we start
merging we start heavily more inter
disciplinary Fields I want to you know
what happens when the when the guitarist
paints what happens when the painter
sews I'm really interested in these
intersections use the things we're
really good at it's like it's like my
literary skills that make me really good
at math or the way that I talk like I
don't plan this look at how I speak how
is that it's the artistic side you know
and are these actually uh mutually
opposed no so I think what we should do
is like Advocate again for like this
multiness not not thesis antithesis
synthesis how about thesis antithesis
negative dialectic so that every voice
is heard how do you do that
in a way that is not leads to like utter
chaos it's through the dialysis way can
you see points both points of view can
you see both of these can they make
sense in both ways
um and also to reincorporate like
imagination imagination don't forget it
don't forget the value of creativity in
these things and to really hone the aha
moment like take care of it you know so
we're introducing something that's like
let us be more like more more caring in
these fields so when you think like and
think about the sense of self that
drives the next space
so we're thinking like hey let's take
this what does math art actually mean
math art is now an it's like a you know
a dynamically growing portal
neurodiversity right can we amplify the
variations in these fields
and that's why I think you know it's
going to get a lot of resistance with
like no no why my field is this you know
my field is this you know but we're into
amplifying the variations and whatever
actually actually made that field you
know so I think it's like now is like
The Best Time Ever to like you know it's
like amplify fep Through Math art are
there actually mirrors of each other the
mirrors of each other in a way that
doesn't die out it's like what happens
when two mirrors see each other that's
what we're after here it's like we can
actually try to get a more um
and more dynamical definition of self
and to not just toss it away and to say
deficit this deficit this deficit this
deficit this you know it's like oh tell
me how you see things how do you see
things because we all know you see what
you are
is undeniable you see what you are uh
inner thought outer thought inner sound
outer sound so we're here to like
I I think the more people in the room
the better right so these very
um like exclusive uh um uh institutes I
just work on this I just work on this I
think like again my ultimate aim is to
have this like Universal Institute where
everybody's working everybody's working
because you know what it's going to do
it's going to refine that problem in a
way that's Universal so I'm really into
Universal languages Universal problems
can you take that rigid point of view
that you have and make it daily theistic
can you imagine can you imagine
everybody problem solving by Universal
languages or by dialethisms then then
the nature would already be you know
people that have six languages it's
impressive it's amazing because they can
just pot like tilt tilt tilt tilt like
the basis is universal but I can tilt if
I actually need to I can tilt and just
speak English or I can tilt and just
speak Mandarin whatever but I am trained
in the higher dimensional space so I
actually think that we do have these
like Jedi powers and we need to actually
actually like retrain ourselves and
don't forget that imagination is a gift
so if we can actually use it and not
have it so excluded in the heart
Sciences like it's like that aha moment
is what led me to that you know that is
pure aha thinking and then you know
perhaps if we were more gentle to things
like that we wouldn't lose people like
graph Indy if you wouldn't lose these
you know what I mean like you just have
to be more caring and open up the
neurodiversity realm so that's what um
and all the things that I'm in it's like
that's my new like advocation line and
so Chris and I think that through more
interdisciplinary works you know we can
actually hone that dialysis you can
actually hone amplifying variations
um
yeah and amplifying like adaptivity so I
think the only way to survive like
what's going on right now is to be
adaptive right and so we just want to
merge Fields so that we can actually you
know
uh merge a lot of like math into
neurology so it's like Could you
actually have a brain as a you know
could you have a quantum mechanical
notion of the brain brain is hologram
you know is there a non-local behavior
in the nervous system
right a lot of neurologists are not
trained and stuff like that right but
Infuse the mathematician and maybe we
are so after the NOC talk I gave like
you know these really brilliant like
neurologists reached out like hey I
really like the model that you're doing
so I just want all of us to sort of like
work together so if we could pause at
that Universal Institute I think that's
in the nature of like fep you know
I don't know if what I said made any
sense but you can tell that like I care
and so what are we trying to do it's
like we're not stopping with this notion
of self we're going to try to come up
with theory of thoughts and we're just
going to keep going until like
um we try to reach that universal
language you know like we're comfortable
with like limit paradoxes and we'll say
it up front
what is the nature of true contradiction
the fact that you can still understand
me in this very nature you still exist
but I don't know how
well very nice I'll add a few thoughts
as we come towards our column closing
so different fields connect different
fields first couldn't ask for a better
last name or collaboration to make it
happen
and you integrating different fields
like Building Bridges between different
agricultural Fields they're different
spatial locations or is it actually like
the Electro and the magnetic fields in
the sense that these fields are actually
different measurement devices might pick
up on one or another or one mathematical
model might consider these fields but
they're not spatially adjacent
or sequential but rather they're
overlapping and they're enmeshed and
therefore how we model those fields and
how they're connected it's like that was
the transdisciplinarity that we needed
it wasn't a problem out there to be
solved by concatenating or composing it
was something about our own process and
then just one lost to those General
and um important social and
participatory comments you brought up
in some other work we've been thinking
about how the disciplinary model
groups people according to their
identities affiliations and their
practices so biology Department might
have Affinity with other departments at
that school or with other biology
departments and there might be a culture
of microscopy and there's the person
who's skilled in microscopy and those
practices are what create that Locus it
becomes that kind of a thing and the
person with a microscope might be asking
identical questions and have identical
uh intentions and intentions to somebody
who's using a satellite imagery or
somebody who's writing poetry yet the
disciplinary model has fragmented those
latent possibilities and so in contrast
with that disciplinary model based
around shared practices and identities
and affiliations
in a Commons model
people are linked through their shared
concern their shared stewardship and
their meaning and in those situations we
can be some people enjoying the park
some people are clipping the Roses other
people are researching which fertilizer
to use or if we even need fertilizer and
there can be many practices and
affiliations at the public park under
the auspices of a Commons and so
potentially thinking of the epistemic
ecosystem as a Commons to be stewarded
collectively rather than some sort of
corpse to dissect in a disciplinary
fashion might bring some new people into
the picture
wow I love the shared stewardship like
that is so that is so beautiful you know
it's like wow can you imagine if like
every hard science had to have an
elective like
building a garden
can you hold that harsh theorem and like
take care of like a plant like that
would be wow that would be so amazing
Daniel I think we have to like
Wow Let's grow a plant Let's uh let's
make a shared sewer like stewardship
wouldn't that be so cool like here's the
you know they kind of do it with like
Trade Tech and stuff like that like tech
places but I think like yeah it's almost
like elon's at Astra it's like let's
make it add like ad infinitum Universal
or something like that you know
take it to the Limit
let's do it I'm so down it's like I mean
you have the audience for it you know
like this what a great Community yeah
shared stewardship
wow hopefully one day
let's keep fighting for it indeed well
thank you so much
what an amazing conversation really
happy that you're all working on this
vector and that you made time out to
speak with us so
great times
thank you so much for having us and
thank you for your lovely community that
supports us
thank you farewell
bye